but we're going to begin this half-hour
with this Starbucks is apologizing to an
Arizona police department after six
officers were apparently asked to leave
a store on the fourth of July now this
was because a customer said the officers
made him feel unsafe the coffee giant
faces a growing backlash online it
includes the hashtags dumped Starbucks
and boycott Starbucks Jamie yuccas is
outside the Starbucks in Tempe Arizona
where it took place so Jamie help us
understand this isn't the first time
that Starbucks has been criticized for
its treatment of customers so what's the
company's response to this time yeah
Gail it's not Starbucks released a
statement calling the incident
completely unacceptable and it also
mentioned that it's actually in the past
partnered with the Tempe Police to host
the community outreach event coffee with
a cop now it's sent executives here to
apologize face to face the Association
for the Tempe Arizona Police Department
says on the 4th of July six officers
were enjoying their drinks at this
Starbucks ahead of their holiday shift
when a barista asked them to leave
because a customer complained their
presence made him feel unsafe after the
officers left the Association tweeted
several of those cops are veterans who
fought for this country hashtag zero
respect alongside a dumped Starbucks
image it's a message that quickly began
trending online along with the hashtag
boycott Starbucks Association president
Rob Ferraro later went on Fox News and
clarified his organization's stance
we're not asking for a boycott of
Starbucks and we don't want the employee
fired hopefully this is a learning
opportunity we can move forward
some people are also backing the
customer who complained on Twitter one
user wrote I don't feel safe around the
police ever you need to work harder to
earn our respect and Trust and another
wrote that perhaps the customer felt
unsafe because of a history of racial
profiling and police brutality in
Arizona in January a Tempe police
officer shot and killed a 14 year-old
boy
suspected in a burglary police say he
was carrying an airsoft replica handgun
this shooting drew outrage in the
community
the
resigned and the shooting is being
investigated last year two black men at
this Starbucks in Philadelphia were
arrested after a white employee called
police on them while the men were
waiting for a business meeting inside
the store Philadelphia PD later
apologized I think what occurred was
reprehensible at every single level in
an interview with Gayle King shortly
after former Starbucks executive
chairman Howard Schultz also apologized
in response Starbucks closed its more
than 8,000 stores for a day so employees
could participate in racial sensitivity
training I want to personally apologize
for anyone who has ever felt anything
other than respect and dignity in our
stores the customer and officers
involved in this incident here in Tempe
have not been identified but according
to the New York Times they are all white
men the department tells CBS News it met
with Starbucks executives yesterday and
will continue to talk today as they work
together to strengthen their
relationship Anthony thank you very
confusing I know I'm having a hard time
understanding this story because in most
lists and I know we have issues with the
police in this country but in most cases
the majority of the police officers are
here really to protect and serve and
want to do the right thing want to help
you so I want to know what those
officers were doing that made this
person so uncomfortable seems a better
way to handle that though yeah what the
barista thought was so urgent exactly
his requests and cups are allowed to get
a cup of coffee
exactly more questions on